so what does going to the movies mean
for all of us well that's easy when
we're at the movies were not alone
because we're sitting there watching the
nominees for Best Picture of the year
which are a beautiful mind Brian Grazer
and Ron Howard producers
Gosford Park Robert Alden Bob Balaban
and David Levy producers
in the bedroom friendly to Ross cats and
taught field producers the Lord of the
Rings the Fellowship of the Ring peter
jackson fran walsh and airy and osborne
producers Moulin Rouge Martin Brown Baz
Luhrmann and Fred Baron producers and
the Oscar goes to a beautiful mind Brian
Grazer Ron Howard produces
third Academy Award nomination in the
first Oscar for Brian Grazer
and the second nomination second Oscar
for Ron Howard
for ostrich this evening
yeah it says it was really close
which it was um Iran mmm Kevin great
yikes okay I want to thank the Academy
for selecting our movie I started out in
the business as a writer not a very good
writer but a writer nonetheless I've had
the privilege of working with better
writers great actors and brilliant
directors I found that my calling was to
tell stories as a producer and I just I
loved doing just that in the case of A
Beautiful Mind the storing the subject
were personal and important to me and to
receive an award for making this movie
is a miracle
I want to thank Universal Pictures two
very important and special people to me
Ron Meyer and Stacey Snyder
I want to thank their team including
Scott Peter mark and Nikki DreamWorks
Jeffrey Katzenberg Steven Spielberg and
David Geffen I want to thank Sylvia
Nasar and Graydon Carter and my
dedicated team at imagine Michael
Rosenberg marine Perot Tod Halliwell and
especially Karen key HeLa who is an
amazing partner to me and it for her
enormous contributions Ron Howard okay a
closer friend a better partner a more
inspired and evolving filmmaker I could
never find
thank you Ron for all of that
I'm so nervous uh-uh
I know it's imperceptible um it's my
honor to work with the profound Russell
Crowe and we wouldn't be here if it
weren't for Russell Crowe his amazing
dedication the Dedic dedication work
ethic and artistry have gotten us here
the sublime Jennifer Jennifer Connelly
and all the fine actors on the movie
Akiva Goldsman thank you for creating
this difficult and heart-rending script
and thank you James Horner for your most
original and haunting score thank you to
John and Alicia Nash you have not only
inspired a movie that has given so many
a greater understanding of the vagaries
of the mind but you have given us a
greater understanding of ourselves I
hope in some way our movie helped to
improve the way we feel about and treat
the mentally ill and then and then I
want to thank my little circle of love
my incredible beautiful amazing wife and
my kids
Riley sage and Thomas thank you god
bless and thank you for this support